our next presenters are a very
interesting pair indeed he the elder
statesman of the duo has made that rare
leap from television celebrity to motion
picture stardom having had leading roles
in three major motion pictures his good
friend and colleague is still waiting
for the first big feature film break but
people in the know believe it's just a
matter of time
please help me welcome
kermit the frog and scooter two of jim
henson's muppets
thank you thank you
yes uh listen uh uh animated short films
weave their magic unrestrained by the
limitations of human actors true an
animated character can defy the laws of
gravity
move from place to place without regard
to space or time
and continue to amuse generation after
generation without growing older or
asking for a raise
in short and we aren't
animated characters and the short films
they appear in can do absolutely
anything the imagination can conjure
210 yes and the nominations are
anna and bella celia van dijk producer
the big snip
richard conde and michael scott
producers
second-class male alison snowden
producer
and uh
here's the
open envelope up scooter
uh
open the envelope yes open the envelope
uh
um
i can't
what do you mean you can't we'll uh
well i can't that's all harry's do it
well
this this is the academy awards two
billion people are watching and i just
got through saying that characters like
us can do anything i know but i'm sorry
i just can't um
oh boy
ah this delay is appalling well the
tadpole can't open the envelope but
aren't these things planned i mean this
wouldn't happen on the wheel of fortune
okay
so the winner of the winner
have a froggen mite right there
i haven't used that line before the
winner is anna and bella celia van dyke
producer
thank you thank you
well i'm very grateful
and i'm very proud
to receive this ever today
i have to thank people too
i want to thank
the man who wrote the scripts bergering
the man who did all the designing
burgering
the man who did all the nice animation
burgering
the man who directed the film burgering
and i want to thank you our ministry of
culture affair
who gave us the opportunity to make this
film
thank you thank you
you